you have these weapons that nobody is
familiar with yet if this game that
nobody knows anything about I literally
have no idea about anything from the
game and back to the point where I
should probably actually go research it
before you have this discussion there's
like five projects happening right now
battleborn
Sears Star Wars and nerf team fortress
in some way shape or form and then we're
pitching for tether and peace wag call
it battle born trick shots and then
immediately get into it these aren't
really real trick shots we can't impress
people with like oh wow you may actually
it's like of course we didn't actually
do these trick shots
Renda CG it's a video game you still get
the intro it but the thing is is that if
you're just doing skeet shooting and
you're doing targets and using these
powers it's like that gets boring like
really fast what is so the last thing
you'd expect to happen in a trickshot
video so right now
Nikko wants this fancy nerf turret that
Sam builds the idea is that a bunch of
these guns kind of just come out of I'm
going through and finding some free
sketchup files from 3d warehouse in this
scene you're gonna dodge a few imaginary
shots and after those shots are done do
a flip and get behind him they hang out
on the roof it's like hey that's really
cool but can you would you mind not
doing it while we're working working on
what that's what he said
what makes you think that what you're
doing is more important than what I'm
doing right now I'm flying a drone for
fun the texture is yellow orange and
gray they're flat imagine like a piece
of paper it's very diffused it's not
very reflective I'm going to change
those into reflective textures and
hopefully the shininess will at least
look a little cooler so there's a nice
little slanted mount for the GoPro and
then I got this little 3d printed camera
mount with little bumper here hold my
fat truck in place and like I can't
really use the screen that much suck
right
let's go I'm just I'm trying to find you
I'm behind you I feel like you're really
for wool yeah it looks like it seems
like you're really far away from me
trickshotting to simply into learning
piano this is a kid like that trick
static somebody's loneliness away the
milazzo pet are we imagining the same
thing here are we imagining like watch
this and you see like bounce bounce
bounce do you catch to a box and not to
the box over the cat's in the cart is
like right here right so Sam's standing
here Niko's here the cart is this so
this comes up out of the thing and I'm
right now I'm literally just okay go
ahead
hey it's a transformer Jack's cool
I literally just assembled something
it's not my lorry oh it doesn't matter
because what's cool so you're done all
right here we go
right crashing group haha it looks like
you're gonna have to crash all the time
wha you screamed that's bad flying with
cameras trying to chase each other like
without without adding choreographed it
it's gonna be a couple crashes it's
gonna be glorious like a trickshot that
like affects somebody's emotions changes
fans who they are at their core like
that is easily the highest level future
channel you want but you can't trick
shot her to fall in love with you so
just watching me I can make someone fall
in love with me and she comes easily oh
yeah what can trick shot your way out of
this this is so dumb I have no idea if
any of this is gonna make it into the
final video it still needs a little bit
of refinement as far as like the timing
of the keyframes I need to get the shot
tracked in a thing put into the scene
first so imagine the carts here it's
like it's alright it's alright but it
could be better
that's pretty cool it's like I literally
made a transformer out of nerf guns did
we hit do we hit
holy holy ah ah